I thoroughly enjoyed it and the
directing is Top Notch and he directed
it no this [__] is really I enjoy it
it's unrealistic if you're a boxing guy
why why why most of that I don't I'll
give if I tell you I'll give it all the
ways I don't want to say what do you
mean what do you mean like tell me tell
me what
I don't wait if I tell you
the unrealistic part is
the end
no like the middle it's not like Rockies
were ever realistic yeah even Creed two
Andrew pointed out like Rocky's like you
got a box the guy that's stronger than
you and quicker than you and Andrew's
like no boxer would ever tell you to get
in there with a guy he's got longer
reads you don't want it to be really
fast no not Bob you got to get inside
yeah yeah you want to box the guy who's
stronger than you well Rocky would tell
you that yeah cause Rocky's an idiot
Rocky never did any defense whatsoever
yeah you know what I'm saying like we're
gonna look back on rock and be like he
had Down syndrome yeah I would Down
syndrome he's actually the least most
important person of all the Rocky movies
absolutely not the least Apollo Creed is
the most important person to every great
Rocky movie bro you're black yeah
um
it's a black pride as a fact the first
four Rocky movies and I got this new
Invisalign and so pardon me if I'm
spitting all over you but the first four
Rocky movies are literally centered
around Apollo Creed every single one
Rocky fighting Apollo Creed at the end
of the movie sets Rocky up to okay can't
you say about any antagonist no it's
different right the first Rocky movie
they fight at the end of the movie It's
to draw Rocky gets to fight again for
the championship in Rocky too so both of
those the central figure is Apollo third
movie [__] club of Lane comes Rocky's
Rich he loses all his Mojo gets his ass
whipped by Club elang who motivates him
and gets him back into [__]
shape Apollo Creed right and Apollo only
did that for his own benefit because
Apollo wanted to build him back up so he
could fight him at the end of the
goddamn movie which they never show you
who won but they tell you later on in
the Creed movies then in Rocky IV what
happens Apollo gets [__] killed by
the Russian so now Rocky has motivation
to go to Russia and fight Rocky after
that them Rocky movies fell the [__] off
why are they able to make a Creed
because
[Music]
do you think rock is the most
Progressive movie maybe ever for its
time oh it was a movie made in the 70s
with a dumb white poor boxer and a super
eloquent classy black champ who's like
given though hey let's give this guy a
break I know how to sell the fight he's
like a marketing genius super well put
together
I'll be wondering how fire Adrian
poom-pom was right because think about
it right
she was a decent looking woman right
that's what I think I think Rocky was a
virgin yeah I think they never explored
that the movies I think that was his
first piece of poof when we fell in love
with I love virgins that guy was a bird
I thought he was fighting dudes because
he was so sexually secure I thought that
was the whole point of the movie right
because Adrian didn't you Adrian wasn't
even a good support system before being
honest whoa Adrian doubted Rocky a lot
bro Adrian literally told his
[__] you cannot win in regards
to the Russian sorry she wants to save
his life Charlie man God damn this guy
he killed somebody so believe in me
that's his L'Oreal bro he just needs
that negative
Jordan
[Laughter]
Michael Jordan you're in high school
you're not gonna get some jokes that's
why that b is so important yeah it is
that beat is so [__] important what
does that stand for I really don't know
what the b stands for Mike will be
loving white women Jordan
[Laughter]
he's gonna remember I love Michael you
don't get no credit for Lori Harvey
bakari wow oh
yeah oh wow what do you mean the the
Louis Harvey thing like he dated Laurie
Hart he's a black girl
Laurie Harvey dated Michael B Jordan wow
irregardless
Lori Harvey is having her wait
feel about that I have no idea who wrote
that book for his daughter act like a
lady
what was the book of the first 500 Days
all these rules
Think Like a Man act like a lady that's
what it is yeah whatever the [__] it was
she read that book to a t yeah and she
had been having her way with the way to
Lori Harvey relationship will come out
what would they call it Act Like a Lady
Think Like a Man oh wow I thought that
was Caitlyn Jenner's book okay
by the way
I don't get those awful because she
don't give a [__] no because nobody
gives a [__] about Caitlyn why yeah
because she's so antagonists
[Music]
yeah yeah she said that I mean she was
kind of anti-gaming again yeah yeah she
says I'm attracted to women but I'm not
gay and it's like well then oh are you a
woman attracted to women she just
constantly undermined us people got mad
at me because I said she was a lesbian
this was like when it first happened she
did an interview remember that interview
she did when she when she first came out
yeah and I was like oh so she's still
attracted to the women so she's a
lesbian and they got people got mad at
me you got mad at me for recognizing her
for what she is yeah why would they be
mad at you I have no idea you were in
the future you were too I don't guard
for them yes she is a lesbian and the
most ideal version of a lesbian when you
think about it break it down well the
only issue with a lesbian relationship
is there's nothing to penetrate yeah you
gotta you gotta suction
right only what happened lesbian
relationship is just there's no dick
yeah you gotta get buy a strap-on you
need people okay so they can feel
something yeah yeah okay she can
penetrate the other lesbian feels it she
feels it but they're not that make you
not a lesbian though well no it's your
body parts don't Define you as a man or
woman Charlemagne come on Charlotte it's
how you feel inside so what happens if I
put a penis inside a vagina what is that
called that's just called sex that's a
lesbian sex yeah that's a bunch of
lesbians
no that is super yeah you put a dick
inside a vagina bro
that is wild bro
dude
a lady's dick in a vagina is lesbian sex
bro it's a bunch of bows out there and
we don't believe in that here lady meat
is crazy lady is crazy yeah yeah what
tastes better lady me to be honest they
call it impossible
lady meat is wow now the Beyond beef if
you put the Beyond be in your lesbian if
you put the Beyond beef in your lesbian
girl that is lesbian sex and we have to
respect that yeah simple as that I don't
think we're saying anything provocative
right now nope I don't think so either I
don't know what the [__] you just said
handle Burning Man bro that's why no no
we need we need to get you why do you
want to burn men pardon me what happened